maybe we should begin
even before that at the very base layer
of the wolfram physics project
maybe you can give a broad overview once
again
really quick about this hypograph model
yes and also what is it a year and a
half ago since you've brought this
project to the world what is the status
update
where what are all the beautiful ideas
you have come across
what are the interesting things you can
always mention it's i mean it's a it's a
freaking cambrian explosion i mean it's
it's crazy i mean there are all these
things which i've kind of wondered about
for years and suddenly there's actually
a way to think about them and i really
did not see
i mean the real strength of what's
happened i absolutely did not see coming
and the real strength of it is we've got
this model for physics but it turns out
it's a foundational kind of model that's
a different kind of computation
computation-like model that i'm kind of
calling the sort of multi-computational
model
and that that kind of model is
applicable not only to physics but also
to lots of other kinds of things
and one reason that's extremely powerful
is because physics has been very
successful so we know a lot based on
what we figured out in physics and if we
know that the same model governs physics
and governs i don't know economics
linguistics immunology whatever
we know that the same kind of model
governs those things we can start using
things that we've successfully
discovered in physics and applying those
intuitions in all these other areas and
that's that's pretty exciting and and
and very surprising to me um and in fact
it's kind of like in the original story
of sort of you go and you explain why is
there complexity in the natural world
then you realize well there's all this
complexity there's all this
computational irreducibility you know
there's a lot we can't know about what's
going to happen it's kind of it's kind
of very confusing thing for people who
say you know science has nailed
everything down we're going to you know
based on science we can know everything
well actually there's this computational
irreducibility thing right in the middle
of that
thrown up by science so to speak and
then the question is well given
computational irreducibility how can we
actually figure out anything about what
happens in the world why aren't we
why are we able to predict anything why
are we able to operate in the world and
the answer is that we sort of live in
these slices of computational
reusability that exists in this kind of
ocean of computational irreducibility
and it turns out that seems that it's a
very fundamental feature of the kind of
model that seems to operate in physics
and perhaps in a lot of these other
areas that there are these particular
slices of computational reducibility
that are relevant to us
and those are the things that both allow
us to operate in the world and not just
have everything be completely
unpredictable but there are also things
that potentially give us what amount to
sort of physics-like laws
in all these other areas so that's
that's been sort of an exciting thing
but but i would say that in general for
our project
it's been going spectacularly well i
mean i you know i it's very honestly it
wasn't something i expected to happen in
my lifetime i mean it's you know it's
something where
where it's it's and in fact one of the
things about it some of the things that
we've discovered are things where i was
pretty sure that wasn't how things
worked
and turns out i'm wrong and you know
in a major area in meta mathematics i
i'd be realizing that
something i've long believed we can talk
about it
later that that that uh just just really
isn't right but but i think that um
the um the thing that uh so so what's
happened with the physics project i mean
you know it's a
it can explain a little bit about how
the how the model works but basically we
can maybe ask you uh the following
question so
it's easy through words describe how
cellular automata works you've explained
this
and it's the fundamental mechanism by
which you in your book and your kind of
science explored the idea of complexity
and how to do science in this world of
eye reducible islands and irreducible
general irreducibility okay so how does
the model of hypergraphs differ from
cellular and how does the idea of
multi-computation
differ like maybe that's a way to
describe it right we're yeah right this
is a you know my life is like all of our
lives something of a story of
computational irreducibility yes and you
know it's been going for a few years now
so it's always a challenge to kind of
find these appropriate pockets of
reducibility but let me see what i can
do great so so i mean first of all let's
let's talk about physics first of all
and you know a key observation
that one of the starting point of our
physics project is
things about what is space what is the
universe made of
and you know ever since euclid people
just sort of say space is just this
thing where you can put things at any
position you want and they're just
points and they're just geometrical
things that you can just arbitrarily put
at different different coordinate
positions so the first thing in our
physics project is the idea that space
is made of something just like water is
made of molecules space is made of kind
of atoms of space
and the only thing we can say about
these atoms of space is they have some
identity there's a there's a there is
it's this atom as opposed to this atom
and you know you could give them if
you're a computer person you give them
uuids or something
yes and and um but that's all there is
to say about them so to speak um and
then all we know about these atoms of
space is how they relate to each other
so we say these three atoms of space
are associated with each other in some
relation so you can think about that as
you know what atom of space is friends
with what other atom of space you can
build this essentially friend network of
the atoms of space
and the sort of starting point of our
physics project is that's what our
universe is it's a giant friend network
of the atoms of space
and so how can that possibly represent
our universe well it's like in something
like water you know they're molecules
bouncing around but on a large scale
that
you know that produces fluid flow and we
have fluid vortices and we have all of
these phenomena that are sort of the
emergent phenomena from that underlying
uh kind of collection of molecules
bouncing around and by the way it's
important that that collection of
molecules bouncing around have this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that's actually what
leads to the second law of
thermodynamics among other things
and that leads to the sort of randomness
of the underlying behavior which is what
gives you something which on a large
scale seems like it's a smooth
continuous uh type of thing and so so
okay so first thing is space is made of
something it's made of all these atoms
of space connected together in this
network and then everything that we
experience is sort of features of the of
that structure of space so you know when
we have an electron or something or a
photon it's some kind of tangle in the
structure of space much like kind of a
vortex and a fluid would be just this
thing that is you know it it can
actually the vortex can move around it
can involve different molecules in the
fluid but the vortex still stays there
and if you zoom out enough the vortex
looks like an atom itself like a basic
element yes so there's the levels of
abstraction
if you squint and kind of blur things
out it looks like at every level of
abstraction you can define what is a
basic
individual entity yes but but you know
in in this model
there's a bottom level yeah you know
there's an elementary length maybe
that's 10 minus 100 10 to the minus 100
meters let's say which is really small
you know proton is 10 to the minus 15
meters the smallest we've ever been able
to sort of see where the particle
accelerator is around 10 to the minus 21
meters so you know if we don't know
precisely what the correct scale is but
it's perhaps of the order of 10 to the
minus 100 meters so it's pretty small um
and but but that's that's the end that's
that's what things are made of what's
your intuition where the 10 to the minus
100 comes from what's your intuition
about this scale
well okay so there's a calculation which
i consider to be somewhat rickety okay
which has to do with comparing so
so there are various fundamental
constants there's a speed of light the
speed of light once you know the
elementary time
the speed of light is tells you the
conversion from the elementary time to
the elementary length
then there's the question of how do you
convert to the elementary energy and how
do you convert
to between other things and the various
constants we know we know the speed of
light we know the gravitational constant
um we know planck's constant and quantum
mechanics those are the three important
ones and we actually know some other
things we know things like the size of
the universe the hubble constant things
like that
and essentially this calculation of the
elementary length comes from looking at
these sort of combination of those okay
so the most obvious thing people have
sort of assumed that quantum gravity
happens at this thing the planck scale
10 minus 34 meters which is the sort of
the the combination of of planck's
constant and the gravitational constant
the speed of light that gives you that
kind of length
turns out in our model there is an
additional parameter which is
essentially the number of simultaneous
threads of execution of the universe
which is essentially the number of sort
of independent quantum uh processes that
are going on and that number let's see
if i remember that number that number is
10 to 170 i think and and so it's a big
number but um that number
then connects you know sort of modifies
what you might think from all these
planck
uh
units to give you the things we're
giving and there's been sort of a
mystery actually in the in the more
technical physics thing that the plank
mass
the plank energy
plank energy is actually surprisingly
big the plank length is tiny 10 minus 34
meters that you know planck time 10
minus 43 meters i think seconds i think
um but the planck energy is like uh is
like the the energy of a of a lightning
strike okay which is pretty weird in our
models
the actual elementary energy is that
divided by the number of sort of
simultaneous quantum threads and it ends
up being really small too and that sort
of explains that mystery that's been
around for a while about about how
planck units work but but that you know
whether that precise estimate is right
we don't know yet i mean that that
that's one of the things that's sort of
been a thing we've been pretty
interested in is how do you see through
you know how does you how do you make a
gravitational microscope that can kind
of see through to the atoms of space you
know how do you get in in fluid flow for
example if you go to hypersonic flow or
something you know you've got a mark 20
you know space plane or something it
really matters that there are individual
molecules hitting the space plane not a
continuous fluid the question is what is
the analogous kind of
what is the analog of hypersonic flow
for
for our for things about the structure
of spacetime and it looks like uh a a
rapidly rotating black hole right at the
sort of critical rotation rate um is
it looks as if that's a case where
essentially the the structure of space
time is just about to fall apart and you
may be able to kind of see the evidence
of sort of discrete
uh elements you know you may be able to
kind of see there the sort of
gravitational microscope of actually
seeing these discrete elements of space
and there may be some effect in for
example gravitational waves produced by
rapidly rotating black hole that in
which one could actually see some
phenomenon where one can say yes they
don't come out the way one would expect
based on having a continuous structure
of space time that it is something where
you can kind of see through to the
discrete structure um we don't know that
yet so you can maybe elaborate a little
bit deeper how a microscope they can see
to 10 to the minus
100
how rotating black holes
and uh presumably the
the the detailed accurate detection of
gravitational waves from since black
holes can reveal the discreteness of
space
okay first thing is what is a black hole
actually we we need to go a little bit
further in the story of what space time
is because i explained a little bit
about what space is but it didn't talk
about what time is
and that's sort of important in in
understanding space time so to speak and
your sense is both space and time in
this story are discrete absolutely
absolutely but it's a complicated story
yes and um needless to say well it's
simple at the bottom
it's it's very simple at the bottom it's
it's very in the end
it's simple but deeply abstract and um
and something that is
simple in conception but kind of
wrapping one's head around what's going
on is pretty hard um but so so first of
all we have this so you know i've
described these kind of atoms of space
and their connections you can think
about these things as a hyper graph you
know a graph is just you connect nodes
to nodes but a hypergraph you can have
you know you can have sort of not just
friends
individual friends to friends but you
can have these triplets of of friends or
whatever else it's it's um and so we're
just saying and that's just the
relations between atoms of space are the
hyper edges of the hypograph and so
we've got some big collection of of
these atoms of space maybe 10 to the 400
or something in our in our universe um
and that's the structure of space that's
and every feature of what we experience
in the world is a feature of that that
hypograph that spatial hypograph
so then the question is well how does
what does that spatial hypograph do
well the idea is that there are rules
that update that spatial hypograph and
you know in a cellular automaton you've
just got this line of cells and you just
say it every step at every time step
you've got fixed time steps fixed array
of cells at every step uh every cell
gets updated according to a certain rule
and that's um that's kind of the that's
the way it works now in this hypergraph
it's sort of vaguely the same kind of
thing we say every time you see a little
piece of hypergraph that looks like this
update it to one that looks like this so
it's just keep rewriting this hypograph
every time you see something looks like
that anywhere in the universe it gets
rewritten now one thing that's tricky
about that which we'll come to is this
multi-computational idea which has to do
with you're not saying in in some kind
of lock step way do this one then this
one then this one it's just whenever you
see one you can do
you can go ahead and do it and that
leads one not to have a single thread of
time in the universe
because if you knew which one to do you
just say okay we do this one then we do
this one then we do this one but if you
say just do whichever one you feel like
you end up with these multiple threads
of time these kind of multiple histories
of the universe depending on which order
you happen to do the things you could do
in
so it's fundamentally asynchronous and
parallel yes
yes which is very uncomfortable for the
human brain that seeks for things to be
sequential and synchronous right well i
think that this is this is part of the
story of consciousness is i think the
key aspect of consciousness that is
important for sort of parsing the
universe
is this point that we have a single
thread of experience right we have a
memory of what happened in the past we
can say something predict something
about the future but there's a single
thread of experience and it's not
obvious it should work that way i mean
we've got 100 billion neurons in our
brains and they're all firing in all
kinds of different ways but yet
our experiences
that there is the single thread of of of
time that that goes that that goes along
and i think that you know one of the
things i've kind of realized with a lot
more clarity in the last year
is the fact that our the fact that we
conclude that the universe has the laws
it has is a consequence of the fact that
we have consciousness the way we have
consciousness
and so the fact so i mean just to go on
with kind of the the basic setup it's uh
so we've got this spatial hypograph it's
got all these atoms of space they're
getting they're getting these little
clumps of atoms of space are getting
turned into other clumps of atoms of
space and that's happening everywhere in
the universe all the time and so one
thing is a little bit weird is there's
nothing permanent in the universe the
universe is getting rewritten everywhere
all the time and if it wasn't getting
rewritten it would space wouldn't be
knitted together that is space would
just fall apart there wouldn't be any
way in which we could say this part of
space is next to this part of space you
know one of the things that i was
people were confused about back in
antiquity you know the ancient greek
philosophers and so on and how does
motion work
you know how can it be the case that you
can take a thing that we can walk around
and it's still us when we walked you
know a foot forward so to speak and in a
sense with our models that's again a
question because it's a different set of
atoms of space when we you know when i
move my hand it's it's moving into a
different set of atoms of space it's
having to be recreated it's not the
thing itself is not there it's it's
being continuously recreated all the
time now it's a little bit like waves in
an ocean you know vortices and fluid
which again the actual molecules that
exist in those are not what define the
identity of the thing
and but it's a little bit uh you know
this idea that there can be pure motion
that it can that it is even possible for
an object to just move around in the
universe and not change
is it's not self-evident that such a
thing should be possible and that is
part of our perception of the universe
is that we
we parse those aspects of the universe
where things like pure motion are
possible now pure motion even in general
relativity the theory of gravity um pure
motion is a little bit of a complicated
thing i mean if you imagine your average
you know teacup or something approaching
a black hole it is deformed and
distorted by the structure of space time
and to say you know is it really pure
motion is it that same teacup that's the
same shape well it's a bit of a
complicated story and this is a a more
extreme version of that so so anyway the
the the thing that that's happening is
we've got space we've got this notion of
time so time is this kind of this
rewriting of the hypograph
and one of the things that's important
about that time is this sort of
computationally irreducible process
there's something you know time is not
something where
in kind of the mathematical view of of
time tends to be time is just to
coordinate we can you know slide a
slider turn a knob and we'll change the
the time that we've got in this equation
but in this picture of time that's not
how it works at all time is this
inexorable irreducible kind of set of
computations that go on that go from
where we are now to the future but so so
the thing and one of the things that is
again something one sort of has to break
out of is your average trained physicist
like me says you know space and time are
the same kind of thing they're related
by you know the prank array group and
and lawrence transformations and
relativity and all these kinds of things
and you know space and time
you know there are all these kind of
sort of folk stories you can tell about
why space and time is the same kind of
thing
in this model they're fundamentally not
the same kind of thing space is this
kind of sort of connections between
these atoms of space time is this
computational process so the thing that
the first sort of surprising thing is
well it turns out you get relativity
anyway and the reason that happens the
few bits and pieces here which one has
to understand but but the the
fundamental point is if you are an
observer embedded in the system
that are part of this whole story of
things getting updated in this way and
that
there are there's sort of a limit to
what you can tell about what's going on
and really in the end the only thing you
can tell is what are the causal
relationships between events so an event
in this sort of
an elementary event is a little piece of
hypograph got rewritten and that means a
few hyper edges of the hypergraph were
consumed by the event
and you produce some other hyperedges
and that's an elementary event
and so then the question is uh what we
can tell
is kind of what the network of causal
relationships between elementary events
is that's the ultimate thing the causal
graph of the universe and it it turns
out that well there's this property of
causal invariance
that
is true of a bunch of these models and i
think is inevitably true for a variety
of reasons um that
makes it be the case that it doesn't
matter kind of if if you are
sort of saying well i've got this
hypograph and i can rewrite this piece
here and this piece here and i do them
all in different orders when you
construct the causal graph for each of
those orders that you choose to do
things in
you'll end up with the same causal graph
and so that's essentially why
uh well that's in the end why relativity
works
it's why
our perception of space and time is is
as having this kind of connection that
relativity says they should have
and that's that's kind of that's kind of
how that works
i think i'm missing a little piece uh if
you can go there again you said uh the
the fact that the observer is embedded
in this hypergraph
what's missing uh what is the observer
not able
to state about this universe so
basically if you look from the outside
you can say oh i see
this
uh
i see this particular place was updated
and then this one was updated and and
i'm seeing which order things were
updated in but the observer embedded in
the universe doesn't know which order
things were updated in because until
they've been updated they have no idea
what else happened so the only thing
they know is the set of causal
relationships let me give an extreme
example let's imagine that the universe
is a turing machine turing machines have
just this one update head which does
something and otherwise the turing
machine just does nothing right and and
the turing machine works by having this
head move around and do its updating uh
you know just where the head happens to
be the question is could the universe be
a turing machine could the universe just
have a single updating head that's just
zipping around all over the place you
say that's crazy because you know i'm
i'm talking to you you seem to be
updating i'm updating etc but the thing
is there's no way to know that because
if there was just this head moving
around it's like okay it updates me but
you're completely frozen at that point
until the head has come over and updated
you you have no idea what happened to me
and so if you sort of unravel that
argument you realize the only thing we
actually can tell
is what the network of causal
relationships between the things that
happened were we don't get to know from
some sort of outside sort of god's eye
view of the thing we don't get to know
what sort of from the outside what
happened we only get to know sort of
what the set of relationships between
the things that happened actually work
yeah but if i somehow record like a
trace of this
i guess would be called
multi-computation
can't i uh then look back
in the way
some you place throughout the universe
like throughout
like a log that records
in my own pocket of in this hyper graph
can die
like
realizing that i'm getting an outdated
picture
can't i record see the problem is and
this is where things start getting
very entangled in terms of what one
understands the problem is that any such
recording device is itself part of the
universe yeah
so you don't get to say you never get to
say let's go outside the universe and go
do this
and and that's why i mean lots of the
features of this of this model and the
way things work end up being a result of
that so but what
i guess from on a human level what is
the cost you're paying what are you
missing from not getting an updated
picture all the time okay i got i i
understand what you should say yeah yeah
right but like what like how does
consciousness emerge from that
like how
like wha what are the limitations to
that observer i understand you're
getting uh a delay well that's true
there's a okay so there's there's a
bunch of limitations of the observer i
think
maybe just explain something about
quantum mechanics because that maybe is
a is an extreme version of some of these
issues which helps to kind of motivate
why one should sort of think things
through a little bit more carefully so
one feature of the of this
okay so
in standard physics like high school
physics you learn you know the equations
of motion for a ball
and the the you know it says you throw
the ball this angle this velocity things
will move in this way and there's a
definite answer
right the story the the key story of
quantum mechanics is there aren't
definite answers to where does the ball
go there's kind of this whole sort of
bundle of possible paths and all we say
we know from quantum mechanics is
certain probabilities for where the ball
will end up okay so that's kind of the
the core idea of quantum mechanics so in
our models
you quantum mechanics is not some kind
of plug-in add-on type thing you
absolutely cannot get away from quantum
mechanics because as you think about
updating this hyper graph there isn't
just one sequence of things one definite
sequence of things that can happen there
are all these different possible update
sequences that can occur you could do
this you know piece of the hypograph now
and then this one later and etc etc etc
all those different paths of history
correspond to these quantum quantum
paths and quantum mechanics these
different possible quantum histories and
one of the things that's kind of
surprising about it is they they branch
you know there can be a certain state of
the universe and it could do this or it
could do that but they can also merge
there can be two states of the universe
which their next state the next state
they produce is the same for both of
them and that process of branching and
merging is kind of critical and the idea
that they can be merging is critical and
somewhat non-trivial for these
hypographs because there's a whole graph
isomorphism story and there's a whole
very elaborate settlement that's where
the causal invariance comes in yes
among other things right okay yes that
that's but but so so then what happens
is that what what one's seeing okay so
we've got this thing it's branching it's
merging et cetera et cetera et cetera
okay so now the question is how do we
perceive that
what you know how do we do we why don't
we notice that the universe is branching
and merging
why you know why is it the case that we
just think a definite set of things
happen
well the answer is we are embedded in
that universe and our brains are
branching and merging too
and so what quantum mechanics becomes a
story of is how does a branching brain
perceive a branching universe
and the key thing is as soon as you say
i think definite things happen in the
universe that means you are essentially
conflating lots of different parts of
history you're saying
actually as far as i'm concerned because
i'm convinced that definite things
happen in the universe all these parts
of history must be equivalent now it's
not obvious that that would be a
consistent thing to do it might be you
say all these parts of history are
equivalent but by golly moments later
that would be a completely inconsistent
point of view everything would have you
know gone to hell in different ways the
fact that that doesn't happen
is well that's a consequence of this
causal and variance thing but that's and
the fact that that does happen a little
bit is what causes little quantum
effects
and that um if that didn't happen at all
there wouldn't be anything that sort of
is like quantum mechanics it would be uh
quantum mechanics is kind of like in
this
uh in this kind of this bundle of paths
it's a little bit like what happens in
statistical mechanics and fluid
mechanics whatever that most of the time
you just see this continuous fluid you
just see the world just progressing in
this kind of way that's like this
continuous fluid but every so often if
you look at the exact right experiment
you can start seeing well actually it's
made of these molecules where they might
go that way or they might go this way
and that's kind of quantum effects and
and so that's so the this kind of idea
of
where we're sort of embedded in the
universe this branching brain is
perceiving this branching universe and
that ends up being sort of a story of
quantum mechanics that's that's part of
the the whole picture of what's going on
but i think i mean to come back to sort
of where does conscious what is what is
the story of consciousness so in the
universe
we've got you know whatever it is 10 to
the 400 atoms of space they're all doing
these complicated things
it's all a big complicated irreducible
computation the question is what do we
perceive from all of that
and the answer is that we
are we are parsing the universe
in a particular way
let me again go back to the the gas
molecules analogy you know in the gas in
this room there are molecules bouncing
around all kinds of complicated patterns
but we don't care all we notice is
there's you know the gas laws are
satisfied maybe there's some fluid
dynamics these are kind of features of
that assembly molecules that we notice
and then lots of details we don't notice
when you say we do you mean the tools of
physics or do you mean literally are the
human brain in this perception system
well okay so the human brain is where it
starts but we built a bunch of
instruments to do a bit better than the
human brain but they still have many of
the same kinds of ideas you know their
cameras and their pressure sensors and
their these kinds of things they're not
uh you know at this point we don't know
how to make fundamentally qualitatively
different sensory devices right and so
it's always just an extension of the
conscious ex experience or a sensory
experience sensory experience but
sensory experience that's somehow
intricately tied to
consciousness right well so so one
question is when we are looking at all
these molecules in the gas and there
might be 10 to 20 molecules in some
little little box or something it's like
what what do we notice about those
molecules so one thing that we can say
is we don't notice that much
we are you know we are computationally
bounded observers we can't go in and say
okay i'm they're 10 to 20 molecules and
i know that i can sort of decrypt their
motions and i can figure out this and
that it's like i'm just going to say
what's the average density of molecules
and so one key feature of us is that we
are computationally bounded and that
when you are looking at a universe which
is full of computation and doing huge
amounts of computation but we are
computationally bounded there's only
certain things about that universe that
we're going to be sensitive to we're not
going to be you know figuring out what
all the atoms of space are doing because
we're just computationally bounded
observers and we are only sampling these
these small set of features so i i think
the two defining features of
consciousness that and i
you know i would say that the the sort
of the the preamble to this is for years
you know because i've talked about sort
of computation and fundamental features
of physics and science people ask me so
what about consciousness
and i for years i've said i have nothing
to say about consciousness and you know
i've kind of told this story you know
you talk about intelligence you talk
about life
these are both features where you say
what's the abstract definition of life
we don't really know the abstract
definition we know the one for life on
earth it's got rna it's got cell
membranes it's got all this kind of
stuff
similarly for intelligence we know the
human definition of intelligence but
what is intelligence abstractly we don't
really know and so what i've long
believed is that sort of the abstract
definition of intelligence is just
computational sophistication that is
that as soon as you can be
computationally sophisticated that's
kind of the abstract version the
generalized version of intelligence so
then the question is what about
consciousness and what i sort of
realized is that consciousness is
actually a step down from intelligence
that is that you might think oh you know
consciousness is the is the is the top
of the pile but actually i don't think
it is i think that there's this notion
of kind of computational sophistication
which is the generalized intelligence
but consciousness has two limitations i
think one of them is computational
boundedness that is that we're only
perceiving a sort of computationally
bounded view of the universe and the
other is this idea of a single thread of
time
that is that we and in fact we know
neurophysiologically our brains go to
some trouble to give us this one thread
of attention so to speak and it isn't
the case that you know in all the
neurons in our brains that that uh in at
least in our conscious
know the the you know the correspondence
of language in our conscious experience
we just have the single thread of
attention single thread of of perception
um and you know maybe there's something
unconscious that's bubbling around
that's the kind of almost the quantum
version of what's happening in our brain
so to speak we've got the the classical
flow of what we are mostly thinking
about so to speak but there's this kind
of bubbling around of other paths that
is all those other neurons that didn't
make it to be part of our sort of
conscious stream of experience
you